you want the good news or the bad news
the good news first
the supreme court just handed
conservatives a crucial win on an
important question of religious liberty
all right the bad news the courts have
been clobbering us at almost every turn
on top of that
a new report out of harvard shows how
the lockdown dramatically ramped up
the rate at which conservatives are
losing political power
and joe biden proves me right on
juneteenth you know
i hate to say i told you so i'm michael
knowles it's the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from jay desteff who
says biden telling putin not to attack
certain things is like the kid telling
the bully no swirlies or wedgies but
noogies are okay that is true
and by the way what happens when the kid
tells the boogie no swirlies or wedgies
but noogies are okay the kid is going to
get swirlies and wedgies biden doing
that is just saying hey vlad
come on in here buddy that's what you
got to attack that guy man joe biden he
doesn't know what's going on at all i
probably don't know what time it is
one reason for that of course that he
may not have a movement watch
you know that i love nice timepieces
i do i love them well in a tiny
apartment
in southern california two college
dropouts teamed up to create a watch
company
that broke all the rules with fair
prices unexpected colors
clean original designs movement grew
into one of the fastest growing watch
brands
all over the world they shipped to over
160 countries across the globe
now movement has expanded into the blue
light glasses that protect your eyes
from your screens
minimalist jewelry and more style
essentials that do not break the bank
all designed out of their california
headquarters
movement watches have the look and
quality of a 400 500
watch you're paying for at a department
store but they cost a fraction of the
price because they were built
online and own their process from start
to finish you get a beautiful watch
shipped right to your door
for free and if you don't love it you
can ship it
right back for free i would really these
guys have been with the show
for so so long from the very beginning
if you want to elevate your look
with style that does not break the bank
join the movement get 15 off day with
free shipping and free returns by going
to mvmt.com
knowles mvmt.com
knowles good news out of the supreme
court i don't want to downplay it this
is good news
fulton v city of philadelphia comes out
yesterday
the question in this case was can the
city of philadelphia
force catholic adoption agencies to
give their orphans to same-sex couples
obviously the catholic church does not
support that sort of thing catholic
church is the largest charity in the
history of the world
catholic church does a lot of great work
particularly on adoption
but now that the government in the last
few years has redefined the definition
of marriage
radically they've tried to redefine
reality by redefining the words which
happens to be the topic
of my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
which is available for pre-order
for the next for the next four days and
then
it will be available for order but for
right now you can get a signed first
edition copy of premier collectibles
the government has redefined marriage
radically this puts the catholic church
in a bad position because the
established state church of secular
liberalism
is now quite at odds with the catholic
church with many protestant
denominations with
jewish denominations i know there are
different
sort of forms of judaism with muslims
with all sorts of groups
who do not got into this sort of thing
so the supreme court had to answer this
question
ca in the interest of equality and
individual rights and the new definition
of marriage
can the government force catholic
charities
to give orphans to same-sex couples the
court ruled
unanimously no
frankly regardless of what you think
about the definition of marriage
it should terrify you if
the regardless of what you think about
the particulars of this case
if the government can come in and force
any religious group
any non-profit whatsoever to just
violate
some of its most basic beliefs and
including
in the way that they are giving children
orphans to be housed
there is no limit to what the government
can do so the court ruled unanimously
nine to nothing that the city of
philadelphia can't do that
good stuff right that's a win however
we get a bunch of losses at the court
too supreme court ruled seven to two
to reject a challenge to obamacare this
is now the third
time the court has weighed in on
obamacare this challenge came from texas
attorney general ken
paxton and 17 other republican attorneys
general
uh the court rejected this not on any
question of the of the
obamacare law itself so much as the
question of standing
do these attorneys general have standing
to even bring the suit
the court said seven to two no they do
not
this is just another time the court has
sort of changed its reasoning as to why
it's going to uphold obamacare
there have been many different reasons
some of which seem sort of contradictory
but and actually clarence thomas pointed
that out in his in his opinion here
even though he did agree with the
reasoning on this case but obamacare
here to state the court's just never
never going to do anything about it and
then at the lower courts poor old jack
phillips you know our friend jack
phillips
who owns masterpiece cake shop he has
been on this show he hasn't been on in a
while but he's been on this show before
he is targeted by radical sexual
revolutionaries
who want to force him to make custom
cakes
for all sorts of purposes not just
same-sex wedding ceremonies
but also really radical stuff involving
gender ideology things that
really violate his conscience and his
religious beliefs
they target jack phillips not because
he's the only baker in colorado there
are actually
very liberal left-wing bakers just down
the street from him they do it because
they want to crack him they don't want
him to have the right to practice his
religion
they keep dragging him to court and a
court just ruled against him
colorado court ruled to punish jack
phillips
for refusing to design a cake that
celebrates a gender
transition a gender transition which is
not a thing it doesn't
it's not possible to go from a man and
become a woman
this is impossible this view of human
nature violates
jack phillips's beliefs it happens to be
incorrect as well
and the court said nope the state
established church of secular
progressivism
the state established church with the
sacrament of gender transition will
impose upon you
this religious ritual and you got to do
it
i happen to think as happy as i am about
this catholic
adoption agency's case i just think guys
we're
our bar is a little too low here as
conservatives
we are we are celebrating now
that the state for now will not
take orphans out of the hands of nuns
and give them
to same-sex couples against the wishes
of the people running the orphanage
that and to violate their religious
views which would effectively have to
shut down all the adoption agencies
which is probably what the liberal
establishment wants
that's our celebration whoopee there was
a case
as part of the obamacare case yesterday
there were some conservatives who were
actually
gloating they said aha
you see we were told the liberals told
us that if
amy coney barrett were confirmed to the
court she would be the decisive
blow against obamacare but look she
voted to uphold obamacare
that shows you libs yeah we're gonna
uphold obamacare to own the libs yeah
that's right you think gosh if we own
the libs anymore we're not gonna have a
country left
so that's not the sort of thing to
celebrate folks
good i'm glad that catholic orphanages
can continue to operate
for now who knows how long that will
last
but if that's victory and we've lost on
every
other issue and if poor jack phillips
has lost his life at this point
his livelihood rather because now all he
does is deal with these radical
revolutionaries in court then
maybe we need to rethink our legal
strategy maybe the conservative legal
movement has not been particularly
effective the squishes really uphold
this idea the squishies love this idea
that liberalism is a neutral playing
ground and look at the wonderful
victories
the catholic church is still allowed to
have adoption agencies for now well
i want a little bit more than that folks
and i think we need to pay a little more
attention to these cultural issues
speaking of which you know i've taken i
guess
i guess it's an unpopular position let
me rephrase that
i've taken a position that is very
popular among the american people
but is very unpopular among the media
among commentators among politicians in
the democratic party and in the
republican party
namely juneteenth should not be a
federal holiday i have a column up it's
a
somewhat longer column at the daily wire
you can read my
arguments for that i've mentioned a few
of them on the show here but you can
read that that's up now and it's causing
lots of
controversy and consternation but my my
main argument the main thrust of my
argument was this is not about
recognizing
the freeing of the slaves the purpose of
this taking this local holiday from
galveston texas
and pretending that it's a very big
important national holiday and then
actually
establishing it as our 11th annual
national federal holiday
is to create an alternative to
independence day
and i knew this was happening uh this
was to create a holiday bereft of
gratitude that's really focused on the
resentment of our evil terrible rotten
country
the title of the bill is the juneteenth
national independence day bill
it's it's right there in the title that
it's an alternative to the fourth of
july
during the the debate over this in the
house
so much of the democratic debate focused
on the evils of our country
and then joe biden signed it into law
yesterday and joe biden
explained exactly what i told you was
going to happen
june 18th marks both the long
hard night of slavery and subjugation
and a promise of a brighter morning to
come
this is a day profound in my view
profound weight and profound power
a day in which you remember the
moral stain the terrible toll
that slavery took on the country and
continues to take
what i've long called america's original
sin
at the same time i also remember the
extraordinary capacity
to heal and hope and to emerge
from the most painful moments in a
bitter bitter
version of ourselves but to make a
better version
of ourselves the stain
the e this day is about remembering the
stains of america the original sin
but mind you of course slavery is not
america's original sin
original sin is america's original sin
but we don't have any words to talk
about that anymore i guess in our moral
discourse
this is a day to remember how terrible
america is
how much slavery how much pain slavery
has inflicted on the country
and how much you know obama in biden's
words
it continues to inflict on the country
today
the only hope he's talking about is in
the future it's not
a day to celebrate victory it's not the
emancipation proclamation it's not the
13th amendment it's this kind of weird
inconclusive
overdue day that we're memorializing
that still isn't done it's a day to
revel
in resentment and that will be the
reframing of american history
for those of you i know that there are
some people out there who are
conservatives who say this is a huge win
for conservatives we're celebrating the
day the republicans freed all those
democrats slaves
right this is a great day we're going to
celebrate abraham lincoln
are we is that is that what they're
talking they're talking about
celebrating abraham lincoln you heard
that from joe biden
no if this juneteenth national
independence day is such a win
for conservatives how come all the
people that pushed for it are democrats
how come some conservatives are opposed
to it right now and all the people
celebrating it are democrats why because
they think it's such a big win for
republicans
are they just mistaken no i think
probably many republicans are mistaken
in not understanding the import of this
day
at a national i'm not talking about the
local galveston holiday i'm talking
about the national level
the new national independence day it is
a day for resentment
be prepared for the way that this will
be talked about be prepared for
everything when you want to be prepared
go check out
ready wise now is a better time than any
to be prepared with long-term
nutritional food options ready wise has
many options such as
emergency meals freeze-dried fruits and
vegetables for convenient on-the-go
nutrition
new adventure meals for hiking camping
and other outdoor activities
ready wise makes being prepared simple
and affordable order online
and have nutritious meals shipped
directly to your doorstep
when government resources are strained
it can be days if not weeks before fresh
food is available do not put yourself in
a situation
when you need food during an emergency
prepare today
each meal is a combination of both
dehydrated and freeze-dried ingredients
meals are packed
into durable long-lasting pouches
designed to keep food fresh
for up to 25 years do it
if the last year has not taught you to
be prepared i don't know what will
this week my listeners can get 10 off at
readywise.com when entering knowles 10
at checkout or by calling 855 453 2945
readywise has a 30 day no questions
asked return policy no risk in taking
the initiative
to get you and your family prepared
today that's readywise
r-e-a-d-y-w-ise.com
promo code knows 10 to get 10 off racial
grievance
has taken on such social currency it it
may be the most valuable thing in the
country right now
grievance in general sexual grievance
all sorts of grievance
that grievance is what the juneteenth
national holiday is about
i'm distinguishing it from the local
tradition that in very few places people
have celebrated i'm talking about the
national thing that even left-wing
outlets like salon.com admit
that just have not been known at a
widespread level until very recently
through the machinations of leftist
activists
in newark new jersey right now
people have erected a 700 pound
statue of george floyd
george there is now a monument and a
memorial
to george floyd people are taking photos
with it
like he's a hero like he's a saint
george floyd was an unreformed career
criminal
who robbed pregnant women at gunpoint he
held a gun to a pregnant woman
while his buddies robbed her he died
while resisting arrest for committing
another crime it's not even like look
saint paul was a murderer people turned
their lives around
this guy didn't he was killed
under these dubious circumstances and in
a very
very problematic trial where you had
political pressure all the way up to the
president of the united states
and threats of riots from from
congressmen eventually
that they convicted him of murder but i
i suspect
they're going to have quite a lot to
talk about on the appeal
but even so sure dubious circumstances
no question about it lots of questions
the whole reason george floyd was on the
ground is because he asked to be taken
out of the cop car
why did he ask to be taken out of the
cop car unclear he was obviously very
high on drugs at the time
but even the claim that the cop
callously refused to
to get off of him off of his neck and
then we
learned it was actually also his
shoulders when he said i can't breathe
is because he was saying i can't breathe
before the cop ever really even touched
him
this i'm not saying that
we're we know that this was a justified
arrest we know exactly how he died we
really don't even though the court ruled
we know that there was a lot of pressure
on that court
a lot of irregularities but even so
let's let's say it was a totally
unjustified killing
let's say the guy was murdered you erect
a statue of an unreformed criminal
only you only do that in a culture
that values grievance
and racial resentment over
virtue sanctity holiness patriotism
courage
all of these sorts of things absolutely
insane but it's why it's happening now
this is the other point i make on the
juneteenth national holiday
if this is really just oh it's a great
thing we're just celebrating this
holiday that's it's been around for
forever it's been around for 100 years i
mean no one's ever heard of it but no
it's been around for so long and
what you never heard of juneteenth yeah
okay
why now why is there this big push
right now do you think it has to do with
remembering the glories of the union
troops and abraham lincoln
or do you think it has more to do with
the
racial resentment narrative that has
cropped up and that has actually
exploded
literally onto the streets of our
country burning down city after city
notably during the blm riots of 2020.
what do you think it's more about
what do you think it's more about
actually i know what it's about because
people say
why are holidays created columbus day
was created
in part for the 400th anniversary of the
great the great explorer
in part because italians the previous
year had been the victims of the largest
mass lynching in american history so it
was in part
to seem to make amends to italians and i
suspect that's what's going on here it's
to make amends
to black people in america
what what will this accomplish what will
it do what is the amend specifically for
i suspect it's not a whole lot has
changed in the last
several decades i suspect what it's for
is this canard
of the epidemic of systemic white racism
and the cops and the killers and the
white supremacies the greatest threat to
america whatever merrick garland told us
it's a it's a false narrative that's
being pushed
and republicans sadly going along with
it
going along with it some very
woke black people though i mean woke in
the best sense of that term
recognize that this racial narrative is
just
garbage it's trash it needs to be
rejected it is
insidious and it's harmful to black
people themselves like this
man who recently spoke at a
an illinois school board meeting he said
you think that i'm being kept down by
the white man well if i'm being kept
down by the white man then how am i so
successful
you talk about critical race theory
which is pretty much gonna be teaching
kids how to hate each other
how to dislike each other that's pretty
much what it's doing
that's pretty much all cameron said it's
pretty much what it's going to all come
down to
you're going to deliberately teach kids
this white kid right here
got it better than you because he white
you're going to personally tell a white
kid
oh the black people are all down and
suppressed how do i have two medical
degrees if i'm sitting here oppressed
how do i get first of all cause i only
got five minutes now
five minutes two medical degrees no mom
no dad in the house work my way through
college sat there and hustled my butt
off to get through cops you gonna tell
me somebody who looked like all your
white folks
kept me from doing that are you serious
not one white person ever came to me
saying well son you're never gonna get
anywhere because you know the black
people
but guess what what's sickening about
this whole thing is what y'all doing
right now is already something i do in
my community right now to speak out
against stuff because
black folks are getting told by other
black folks oh you know you ain't going
to do nothing out there in the world
because then white folks ain't going to
let you get no
you know you're not going to do it
because you know what the white man the
white man gonna keep you down well how
did i get where i am right now
if some white man kept me down how am i
now directing over folks that look just
like you guys in this room right now how
what what kept me down what oppressed me
what oppressed me
you know there was one time i was giving
a speech at a college in
los angeles it was me and drew giving
the speech
and at one point a group of entirely
black
students come into the room with duct
tape over their mouths
and some of it said silenced or whatever
some of it was just the tape and they
obviously didn't know anything about
me or drew or the young americas
foundation which was hosting it
and they it was just that usual canard
that anybody that opposes radical
leftism is a racist and a bigot
and a terrible person and
so they had also had no idea what we
were talking about so i said hey
uh we've got these microphones up here
uh you you seem to be uh
you seem to be under the impression that
you're silenced uh so does anybody want
to come up here and talk
do any of you guys with the tape on your
face want to come talk
because i've got a microphone you can
make whatever point you want or ask
whatever question you want i'm happy to
talk about it
nobody would do it nobody would they
didn't have anything to say
you might say they were speechless
it's titled my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
which is available for pre-order but not
for for much longer
they were silenced they had put the tape
over their own mouths
i asked them that question i said who
put that tape on your mouth was it
was it the white man was it the system
was it the
the powers that be no of course not
it was uh they themselves who who had
done it
now this guy this father who was
speaking the school board meeting
absolutely right
about this pernicious ideology critical
race theory it's just
it's just awful when we talk about how
it's anti-white racism so that's bad bad
for white people
also bad for black people because it
creates this culture of victimhood and
grievance that will not serve anybody
well
speaking of educational decline i had to
read
to you a headline from a new study it
shows you how stupid we've gotten in
this world
this was from the guardian headline
aging process is unstoppable
finds unprecedented study
immortality and everlasting youth are
the stuff of myths according to new
research
new research which may finally end the
eternal debate about whether we can live
forever
how much oh my gosh how much
money do you think these these
researchers wasted
uh undertaking this shocking
unprecedented study that found out that
men are mortal you idiots
oh my gosh i've heard this from some of
my kind of futurist friends generally
they're
more of my liberal friends who say you
know we're gonna find the cure to death
we are probably within our lifetimes
maybe we'll just miss it but
we're gonna they're gonna they're gonna
cure death okay we're gonna
we're gonna figure out the way to solve
all the ailments of age and we're going
to live forever and i thought you know
pharaohs evil geniuses
dictators billionaires they've all
sort of tried at this and it's always
very foolish
this is the stuff of myth and legend we
want to live forever and part of the
human condition is
coming to grips with this apparent
tragedy that we
will die the fact of our own mortality
one may have life
everlasting but you're not going to find
it in this mortal coil
we we no longer even know that our
scientific geniuses no longer even know
that man is a mortal being what else do
they not
know they don't know anything about men
but you know you know there are some
things i know for certain about men the
manliest of men have high cheekbones
they have swarthy skin they have nice
deep voices they smoke cigars but the
second manliest of men
have beards beard supply has top
selling products such as beard oils soap
beard shears
and beard bomb when you go to
beardsupply.com
you use code knolls on a subscription
product you will get
fifty five zero percent off your first
month
not only does fifty percent off the
first month sound great but subscribing
comes with its own perks
get your product of choice automatically
delivered every one two or three months
your choice never worry again about
running out of product and remember
use cold knolls for 50 off your first
month
of the subscription go sign up right now
so that you two can start grooming to
get closer
to that iconic matt walsh beard which
will allow you to look
like one of the manliest men at the
daily wire
not the manliest man not you know not
with the
swarthy skin on the high cheekbones and
all but it'll help you go a long way
beardsupply.com code knowles
there's really bad political news that
has come out of the coronavirus
lockdowns obviously we've lost a lot of
our political rights they shut down
churches for a long time they completely
overhauled the election procedures to
take away a lot of voter integrity
measures
there are a lot of political problems
okay with the lockdowns
but the biggest political problem for
conservatives
is that it has eroded the political
power
of our main constituency on the right
there was a new report that just came
out yesterday
from uh used data from harvard brown
and the gates foundation showed
that the coven 19 lockdowns had a far
worse effect on middle-class americans
than on very rich americans
so back in january and march 2021
americans earning above 60
000 a year observed a 2.4
overall increase in employment they
they actually they increased their
employment right
workers earning below sixty thousand
dollars a year
and workers earning below twenty seven
thousand dollars a year
saw a four point five percent and twenty
three point six percent
decrease in their employment
respectively
so the the lowest classes are getting
hit very very hard as well but the thing
that we've got to worry about is the
middle classes
the rich go up the poor
the quite poor don't forget have
access to government programs and more
stimulus and more unemployment but the
middle class
gets squeezed the middle class
traditionally
has been the conservative constituency
the the lowest classes
tend to be easy prey for democrats to
promise them goodies
the upper classes are part of the ruling
regime
they tend to go for the democrats but
the middle
that's where the conservatives thrive
and the middle is getting
squeezed really really squeezed
this has been true since the 70s at
least
and it's getting worse and worse and
worse
and conservatives are ignoring this at
their own
peril so there has been much talk of the
great reset
you know what is what is the great reset
well it's this is not a conspiracy
theory in as much as
many world leaders have used this very
phrase they've said
that we need to come out we need to
build back better
and come out of the pandemic stronger in
a new economy that's better for global
warming and better for international
cooperation
whatever whatever nonsense
they are explicit in their goal of
revolutionizing society there's nothing
new that didn't start with the pandemic
that's been going on for a long time
and the key to that is going to be to
breaking down the intermediating
institutions
and political blocs that are stopping
them from taking
more and more and more power and so much
of that is going to be in the middle
class
any successful conservative political
movement in this country
it's not going to be shilling for
billionaires it's just not it's good
when billionaires donate money to help
us
win campaigns but it's not going to be
showing for billionaires it's not going
to be showing for multinational
corporations
it's not going to be winning over the
most
destitute of the destitute it won't and
it's you know we want we want to welcome
everybody into our party
but just as a practical political matter
it's going to be
in the middle and if it's not in the
middle then we're just going to lose
lots of our rights are being taken away
right now mark
and patricia mccloskey you remember them
they should be the cover of
of the brooks brothers catalog as far as
i'm concerned the guy wearing the he was
that it actually was a brooks brothers
shirt wearing a pink polo shirt
nice chinos holding his ar-15 his wife
with that little
what is that like a walther ppk or
something it's a little like james bond
gun
standing out when the blm riders busted
through their property
they've now pled guilty to misdemeanors
and had to surrender their weapons to
saint louis authorities
think about how crazy they charged him
with felonies and they just had to plead
it down
the mccloskeys did nothing wrong they
could use a little better trigger
discipline but they
they did nothing wrong armed criminals
busted onto their property broke some of
their property
threatened their lives these two pull
out their weapons
to make sure they never even fire their
weapons
and they're the ones getting in trouble
the blm
terrorists and criminals they get off
scot-free
the mccloskeys who are mostly
responsibly
exercising their second amendment rights
they don't they have to plead guilty to
crimes and they
crimes that they did not commit and they
need to surrender their weapons and
their second amendment right
fake atrocities very important namely
exercising your second amendment right
real atrocities like someone busting
onto your property and threatening your
life are ignored or even
realer atrocities more significant
atrocities like killing a million babies
here through abortion ignored nancy
pelosi was just asked this question
pelosi pretends to be a practicing
catholic sometimes
she uh is an ardent defender of
abortion uh this has become a big issue
now with an
with a nominally catholic president who
nevertheless breaks with
the the church disobeys the church on
very important matters
so this has been a big debate among
bishops do they punish these
these scandalous heretical sometimes
apostate
catholics do they formally excommunicate
them or anything like that
pelosi was just asked about this issue
of abortion her answer pretty weak sauce
the supreme court this fall will review
a mississippi law that bans most
abortions after 15 weeks of pregnancy
is an unborn baby at 15 weeks of human
being
let me just say that i am a big
supporter of roe b
wade i am a mother of five children in
six years i think i have some standing
on this
issue as to respecting a woman's right
to choose is it a human being yes
yes ma'am what kind of an answer was
that
that wasn't an answer at all i like the
reporters saying no i'm just asking is
it a human being
she won't obviously she won't answer
that her answer is
the question of course is do you support
being able to kill babies in the womb
she goes well i've had
five kids so i think i've got a lot of
standing here
as if to say hey nancy pelosi should it
be legal to kill people
uh well i have not killed many people
there are many people that i have not
killed so i think i'm something of an
authority on this question what are you
talking about that doesn't mean anything
but she she just ignores the question
and moves on and there's no scandal here
among
her constituents and among the powers
that be speaking of killers i want to
get to this before we get to the mailbag
vladimir putin was just asked
a question point blank by nbc news are
you a killer a lot of putin critics wind
up dead
are you a killer his answer there's a
lot there there's a lot there
the late john mccain in
congress called you a killer when
president trump was asked
was told that you are a killer he didn't
deny it
when president biden was asked whether
he believes you are
a killer he said i do mr president
are you a killer
i've gotten used to attacks from all
kinds of angles
from all kinds of directions under all
kinds of
and reasons and of different caliber and
fierceness
and none of it surprises me people with
whom i work and with whom
i argue on the international arena we're
not
bride and groom we don't swear
everlasting love and friendship we are
partners
and in some areas we are bribes
as far as harsh rhetoric i think that
this
is an expression of overall u.s culture
so the the reporter pushes him he says
he didn't answer the question and then
he goes
and then he just kind of gives more of
the same theory
that he has here of the way that the u.s
and russia relate
forget about the actual political
question for a second it's quite quite
clear that vladimir putin has killed his
critics
here's the important rhetorical lesson
that we should all learn from vladimir
putin
because the guy's a very effective
politician not saying we need to learn
the substantive stuff
but the rhetorical stuff the technical
stuff we should learn
do not answer your enemies loaded
questions
do not give in to their premises this is
the subject you might know
this is one of the most important
lessons you may have heard
in my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds it
is available now for pre-order for four
more
days uh thank you to everybody who has
pre-ordered at the the numbers are
really really strong
on the pre-order i suspect that there
you know there are
going to be a lot of places not just on
the left but on the squishy right even
very powerful places on the squishy
right that are going to try to ignore
this book
because it contradicts a lot of their
loser strategy and loser rhetoric
and and there are a lot of court jester
conservatives out there who are going to
try to ignore this
so i appreciate all of you pre-ordering
i know a number of people have
pre-ordered multiple copies even
so that's great the signed first edition
uh there is obviously you can get it on
amazon or barnes and noble and
there is the audiobook as well uh which
is read by mwah by yours truly i
i really want to stick one to the
squishes so i appreciate that and you
can order that right now also
amazon you know removed the historic and
moving documentary
which they took down during none other
than black history month
of clarence thomas how do you how do you
remove a clarence thomas documentary
during black history month well the
daily wire has decided to step in and
acquire the north american streaming
rights
so because we're in the movies now so
right now you will be able to
add created equal this is the clarence
thomas documentary
to your daily wire queue take a quick
peek at the trailer
i was never going to be white the
problem is i could never go back
completely to the world i came from
i saw what i had become and then i asked
god and if you take
anger out of my heart i'll never hate
again you're not really black
because you're not doing what we expect
black people to do that's when all heck
broke loose
so you'd still like to serve on the
supreme court i'd rather die
than withdraw from the process
[Music]
that's great i'm so glad we did this i
actually coincidentally i met the guy
who made this movie on
on an amtrak train i did not joe biden
not amtrak joe
certainly not joe biden joe biden was
actually an important figure in this
movie
so you can go stream created equal live
tonight at 9 pm eastern 8 pm central
at dailywire.com if you're not yet a
daily wire member join with code justice
for 20
off your membership get this clarence
thomas documentary and all our other
great content like our talk show candace
our first movie run hide fight and a
whole lot more on demand we'll be right
back with the mailbag
welcome back to the show my favorite
time of the week the mailbag
first question from camille dear michael
i heard your mail bag last week about a
guy expressing his feelings and reaching
out to a girl he knew
while having a girlfriend i'm in a
similar situation well i agree
that if he doesn't break up with his
girlfriend he's just trying to have his
cake and eat it too
if the girl feels the same should she
try to pursue it in a way
that is not a moral i personally know
married couples
who met where one of them was already in
another committed relationship
at what point do you just give up
because they're not single and at what
point do you try sincerely
this was actually going to be my advice
and that's the way you signed the letter
sincerely just because there's a goalie
doesn't mean you can't score
score in a moral way obviously yes this
is a very good point
today we erase all the distinctions
between
local state and federal government
between friendships
and relationships romantic relationships
between dating and marriage and it's all
just kind of fluid man but
look if someone is not yet married
then that opens up certain
more opportunities to pursue those
people than someone who is married then
that person's really off limits but
before that
the guy i ain't married yet okay
yes i think it's important to go after
what you want as long as what you want
is a good thing
and when people are dating they're just
dating you know and
they they can pursue other
options but i wouldn't i suppose what
i'm saying for these people
who they've got a girlfriend or a
boyfriend
but they're actively pursuing someone
else on the side
is eventually they've got to make a
decision
and really before anything happens i
don't think they should be
really you know really exploring all of
those options to the fullest physical
extent
um or even to the fullest emotional
extent
for that matter until they make a
decision because otherwise
you are in a situation where you're
you're getting someone who is
compromising their character
right when a man cheats on his wife
whenever a man when a man leaves his
wife for his mistress
what happens you get a job opening is
what happens
you think that's not going to happen
again it probably will um
so you need to be prudent not just for
the objective
moral questions involved in the
relationship that currently exists
but even just for you you want to make
sure i think it's totally fine
if two people are dating other people
and then they decide they don't want to
date those people anymore they want to
date each other
okay that's fine but that's a
very tricky thing to do you've got to
make sure that
no one's compromising their own
character while they do it
from westin hello michael most austere
and religious podcaster and prodigious
prognosticator who leaves his listeners
speechless controlling words controlling
minds i'm a 23 year old guy
and my issue is that i'm one of the 102
percent of men who are dealing with
addictions to porn
it has seriously harmed my uh
perceptions and relationships of and
with women
my subconscious standards are a messed
up conflation of a good catholic woman
my question besides prayers to the
trinity and all the angels and saints
how do i get to the point where i have a
healthier perception of women and
sexuality
and how could i manifest that in my
relationship with women in general and
hopefully with a woman
in a more intimate relationship thanks
first step cut out the porn i know
easier said than done it's like saying
to a heroin addict hey just put down the
needle
but just do it you can do that one can
persevere certainly with god's grace and
also with the cultivation of virtue
which might take a long time
tools that will help you on this path if
you if you are catholic i suspect you
are from the question
and even if you're not catholic i i
would recommend trying to find something
like this
even if you don't swim all the way
across the tiber namely go to confession
when you go to confession
count your sins name them and count them
it is a humiliating thing
not just on sex stuff on all sorts of
things it's humiliating to name and
count your sins
that's the point that's the point is one
you want you want to confess this
not just in your own mind not just in
the privacy of this very very
individualistic liberal religion that
has taken over
much of the west over the last couple
hundred years but to another person on
your knees that will really do something
and it will create this practical
benefit of you not wanting
to commit that sin again so that you
don't need to tell the priest
and you should you should abstain from
receiving
the eucharist until you do that uh there
are other things you can do
wherever you commit that wherever you
look at the porn wherever you just don't
spend a lot of time there this is the
idea of the near occasion of sin just
don't don't do it this is true not just
to porn it's true of anything you fall
into
if there are places where you are more
likely to fall into that sin
if there are people with whom you're
more likely to fall into that sin
then avoid those places and and avoid
those people
then when you do commit a sin again it's
not just sex stuff it's any kind of sin
do not take that as an excuse to commit
committed 100 million more times you
know in for a penny in for a pound right
no that's not how that works then
i would recommend some kind of
sacramentals even i mean this is now
we're getting really catholic here i
guess but
some catholics will wear things like a
scapular scapular is a
piece of couple pieces of cloth on a
string you wear it around you it's
similar to the kind of broader scapular
of people who are in
monastic orders some people wear little
you know crucifix a little cross on your
neck
a medal these things will just remind
you if you have i don't know if you have
icons or anything in your home
these things will just remind you i'm
speaking in a very practical tangible
way
you will not be quite as inclined to
commit those sins when you've got
a physical reminder there that you
really should not be doing that
that's the first step you are not going
to do this in in the recesses of your
own
mind um you are you are going to do this
through
real practice in the physical world
there's a good book that i would
recommend you read as well called the
spiritual
combat by dom lorenzo scuppoli
really really good book it was written
hundreds and hundreds of years ago and
it's
very very good on these points next
question but you know
you know when you should read that book
you should read it after you read
another
book i'm i i'm going to save the bell
for now i think you know what i'm
talking about from nick
hey michael me again oh nick
oh my god yes i remember you nick thanks
for the advice
last week on the yeah here it is thanks
for the advice on the astrology chicks
i'm no longer seeing any of those women
who collect crystals and whose
apartments smell like a party city on
halloween
however by eliminating those others i'm
now
with a woman i'm glad you've narrowed it
down to one
with a separate potential issue i knew
that when we started dating she was bi
and i thought that it could be fun
because liking hot women is a common
ground that we share
but now i'm wondering if it will become
an issue if we get more serious
sincerely is two company and three
a crowd nick you
you live an interesting life my friend
you know i suspect it's not all that
different
from the lives of many millennials in
gen zeurs but
the fact that this woman that you have
started dating
has had some interesting desires or
perhaps experiences
in her life is not disqualifying
in itself that's true of everybody um
and i suppose that is common ground
liking hot women would be something you
have in common with her
however in your life right now
dating this woman three is a crowd
you know a lot of my friends are libs
and they're a little some of them are
pretty radical out there
and i do know people who have been
involved in all sorts of
crazy relationships with more than two
people and all that sort of stuff
it doesn't work out it does not i've
i've never seen it
work out certainly not before they stop
doing all that sort of stuff
uh do not do it this girl sounds
and interesting and she should be enough
for you and you should be enough for her
frankly and if you're not then tell her
to go take a walk
from james hi michael an old girlfriend
of mine and i these were all
relationship
questions today an old girlfriend of
mine and i are friends on facebook
today she announced to the world that
she was a member of the lgbt lmnop123
yeah
apparently she's demi demisexual
complete with a pride flag
according to wikipedia demisexual people
do not experience sexual attraction
to another unless they have formed a
strong emotional bond with that person
this sounds an awful lot like what a
relationship
used to be meet the person date the
person fall in love with the person then
become intimate rather than swipe right
be intimate then decide if you want a
relationship
is this just another way for people to
jump on the lgbt bandwagon thanks
yes it's a way for people to feel
special it's a way for people
who are in a culture that have that has
rejected
the thing that actually makes them
special namely that they are made in the
image of god
and have human dignity and are
in aristotle's words the political
animal because they have speech
no not yet but some books talk about
this
uh they reject that you know that that
ultimate sort of divine spark of man
that is that is reflected in man and
they try to just
find things about themselves but a man
wrapped up in himself makes a very small
package indeed
and yes this this ex-girlfriend of yours
is now saying
that she's really special and she's you
know
oppressed and she's uh eccentric
because she's a normal woman
who doesn't uh who doesn't just engage
in casual sex in the same way that men
do and doesn't enjoy it as much
that was one of the lies of second wave
feminism is that women relate to sex in
the same way that men do it's not true
it's
frankly i assume that it was just men
looking to get laid
who who came up with second wave
feminism because it gave them
such an advantage in that department and
convinced women
to work against their own interests but
no i suspect all women deep down
just about or demisexuals and
uh your ex-girlfriend is special but not
for that reason
from margot michael sweetheart that's my
name don't wear it out
margo nice to hear from you i am
interested in your opinion on the log
cabin republicans movement within the
conservative party and the conservative
movement
in a previous episode of your show you
talked about how it's difficult to be
both transgender and conservative
what about those who are gay and also
consider themselves to be conservative
shouldn't conservatives be united in
conserving traditional values especially
regarding marriage and sexuality
insert shameless plug now okay i don't
think this is going to count for a ding
because margo's writing insert shameless
plug for a special speechless
controlling words controlling minds here
ding
god bless your number one fangirl margot
great great question margo and great to
hear from you
i think there is a distinction to be had
here
between transgender people who
you know men who believe that they're
women conservatives
quote unquote and homosexual
conservatives
namely if you're a homosexual you are
expressing your sexual desires in a way
that may transgress the moral order
in a way that may transgress tradition
in a way that
in an older time would have transgressed
social mores though i guess today it
would not
um but you are not exactly denying
reality
and you are not forcing others to deny
reality
where i i suppose you know you might say
that they are
denying the reality of the moral order
sure i mean
fine but the transgender movement
is explicitly denying reality and
is coercing all the other people in the
conservative movement
to deny reality as well with the
pronouns and calling
people caitlyn when their real name is
bruce or whatever so i do think
there is a difference here now there are
some squishy conservatives who
who have said with regard to the log
cabin that conservatives need to be
totally on board and
they have to abandon whatever moral or
religious objections they have to
certain sexual acts
and they have to they they have to
embrace the new definition of marriage
and there's nothing greater than that we
all need to wave the pride flag i think
that's
preposterous okay obviously that's not
true
uh however if
understanding these deep moral issues if
understanding that people have different
views of sex
margo i know you're a catholic you know
that i'm a catholic the catholic view of
sex is fairly
restrictive it's not not just
homosexuals
who don't get to do that sort of thing
but many many other
sexual acts are just not permitted and
the same would be true in
islam the same would be true in in other
religions too if
there are people who say you know i have
these sexual preferences i
by my own lights i've really determined
that i think this is okay and this is
how i'm gonna live my life
and i know and that you don't approve of
some of these things
but that doesn't bother me and we get
along and we're all we actually
are trying to oppose the radical left
and we are trying
to advance a political agenda that we
can we can work on together
well i think that's great i'm all for
that i'm not for one of one of the
people who says that we need to
excise you know log cabin or excise all
sorts of people
from the conservative movement just so
long as
it is not a requirement that we all go
along and we all give up our deeply held
moral and religious views the issue of
transgenderism is just
there's no getting around it we are
going to have to use he or we are going
to have to use
she and that's the way it is one last
question from nate hey michael
my name is nate i'm currently going
through a divorce two years after my
marriage due to an unfaithful wife we
have no kids and i
love her with all my heart but can't get
past the betrayal i need all the advice
i can get
please give me some advice that will
help me through this difficult time so
sorry to hear that
i'm really so that's a really horrible
horrible thing that you are going
through
i would recommend this actually ties in
with the previous question because i
know that
i know that these days all sort of
of the christian view of sex it's for
some reason surrounds this
issue of homosexuality or transgenderism
or something but it's
it's really not not about that that what
i would
urge you to do if you can is try to save
the marriage
assuming it was a valid marriage in the
first place which i don't i don't know
i would urge you to try to say that even
going through that horrible horrible
thing
i suspect that would be better in the
long run marriages have survived
infidelity it's a horrible horrible
thing
but that's that's the first thing i
would encourage you to do if you can go
through some sort of
couples therapy or talk to a priest or
that sort of thing
um you know it's easier to fix things
than to build them anew and it's easier
to destroy things than it is to build
that's one of the big lessons of the
left and the right
so i can pray for you though and uh and
i hope that you can repair
this thing that seems like it it's uh
strongly broken all right
i guess that's true of our whole country
i hope we can repair this thing that
seems quite broken
i'm michael moses the michael knowles
i'll see you on monday
speechless
[Music]
here it comes oh no
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 hey everybody
this is andrew clavin host of the andrew
clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me
andrew clavin